in a world where people expect immediate
responses oftentimes and increasingly so
you have to I believe let small bad
things happen constantly to have any
agenda of your own and to get the big
positive things done so it's it's
recognizing that to prevent all her
feelings all mistakes all problems all
of this is impossible and if you try to
do that you'll never have a proactive
schedule of your own is extremely
important so effectively just saying I'm
going to accept the collateral damage
and believe that what I'm embarking upon
is worth more than those minor or
reversible problems and then forging
ahead that's it you got to take a few
flesh wounds ideas are worth nothing
they're not a dime a dozen there are
just nothing all the good founders I
know even the bad founders can come up
with ideas all day long it doesn't mean
anything you have to be able to execute
if an entrepreneur should say start a
business based on one of their passions
or if they should find the most
attractive market opportunity and build
a business out of that whether they like
it or not I think you need both I would
say look here in credit card statement
identify where you spend an unusual
percentage of your income
where are you price insensitive then how
old are you what gender are you where do
you live and design a product that has
all of those things intersecting you
just watch - amazing clips from Tim
Ferriss take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]